Es gibt viel zu tun und keine Zeit zu verlieren.
Awet Tesfaiesus arbeitet ohne Unterlass,
seitdem die Bundestagswahl
ihr einen Platz in Deutschlands
Geschichtsbüchern beschert hat.
Die in Eritrea geborene Anwältin war
schon lange in der Kommunalpolitik aktiv,
bis ein rassistischer Anschlag in ihrem
Bundesland ihr Weltbild erschütterte.
Ich weiß nicht warum,
Hanau hat bei mir einen Punkt erreicht,
wo ich einfach das Gefühl hatte:
Jetzt geht nix mehr.
Jetzt muss sich was ändern.
Ich halte es nicht mehr aus!
Zehn Menschen wurden
bei dem Attentat getötet,
neun von ihnen mit Migrationsgeschichte.
Überkommen von dem Gefühl,
dass Deutschland kein sicherer Ort
für sie und ihre Familie mehr ist,
erwog sie, das Land zu verlassen.
Zur Wahrheit gehört auch,
es ist schwer ein Land zu finden,
welches rassismusfrei ist.
Von daher war die nächste Option:
Wir bleiben hier,
aber geben alles, was wir können,
um gegen Diskriminierung
und Rassismus anzukämpfen.
Hier, im ländlichen Nordhessen,
ist eine schwarze Frau auf dem Wahlzettel
noch etwas Außergewöhnliches.
Aber der Mangel an Vorbildern war
sogar Ansporn für die 47-Jährige.
Denn für sie ist Sichtbarkeit Empowerment.
Wenn unsere … in den Schulen die Schüler
ein Drittel, ein Viertel
Migrationshintergrund haben,
warum haben wir das nicht
auf der Lehrerseite?
Sollte es sein, finde ich.
Ich möchte mich als Schüler:in
auch gespiegelt sehen bei den Lehrer:innen –
und genauso in den Behörden
und genauso in unseren Parlamenten.
Doch während die deutsche Gesellschaft
immer diverser wird,
hinken die Institutionen im Land
statistisch noch hinterher.
Der Bundestag hat 736 Mitglieder.
83 von ihnen haben Wurzeln im Ausland.
26 Prozent der deutschen Bürger:innen
haben Migrationsgeschichte.
Im Parlament sind es
allerdings nur 11 Prozent.
Weniger als die Hälfte
dieser Abgeordneten sind Frauen.
Und bis Tesfaiesus gewählt wurde,
gab es unter ihnen
keine einzige schwarze Stimme.
Aus ihrem beschaulichen Wahlkreis
direkt in die Machtzentrale Berlins.
Dass die erste schwarze Frau
erst 2021 in den Bundestag einzieht,
ist für sie kein Wunder.
Weil wir einfach strukturellen Rassismus
haben in diesem Land.
Und wenn wir sagen, es ist egal,
dann verschließen wir unsere Augen
vor diesen strukturellen Problemen.
Dann sind wir nicht bereit zu sehen,
dass ich als schwarze Frau
andere Bedingungen habe,
andere Hürden habe als eine Frau,
die nicht schwarz ist.
Egal wie qualifiziert ich bin.
Noch kommt Tesfaiesus
nur in den Bundestag,
um ihre Post zu holen.
Aber sie kann es kaum erwarten,
endlich loszulegen.
Ja, meine Hoffnung ist natürlich,
dass wir das Thema Chancengleichheit
weiter in den Mittelpunkt stellen.
Dass wir sensibilisieren,
Bewusstsein schaffen,
aber auch inhaltlich was bewegen.
Die neue Abgeordnete hat viele Pläne.
Doch ihr größtes Anliegen ist es,
für andere das Vorbild zu sein,
das sie selbst nie hatte.